and I think the biggest problem then
2018 as now is a self-image
in the minds of the managers who sit there for an
amazing salary this
idea of ​​up to here it has
actually always been enough so who
really wants to go
five years forward
thinking about opening up new business models
that's what we
have to do now, but when we're under a lot of
pressure because one or the
other is already running out of breath or
he says I don't believe in it anymore
and sells titles that are actually
still bringing in good results  we
certainly did one thing at Funke we
unfortunately spent many important years doing this by
always arguing internally about the strategy
so how do we deal
with our dividends that was
the time of our mother then
restructuring the group that was
when  I started in 2018 with
such a mindset, so a change
in the heads as well, which we thought was necessary
other dismissed journalists and
journalists are always tipped overboard
with the focus on optimizing the result,
probably the most honest podcast
I have ever made, namely with Julia
Becker julia is the owner of
Funke Medien, a billion-dollar
company that, above all,
publishes regional daily newspapers, of course,
entirely  had a lot of challenges that
this company inherited about it
also had a lot of difficult
situations because inheriting a company
sounds cool but it's
not that easy we are told
a really emotional
conversation about journalism about
responsibility about the story of
Julia and  Funke Medien let's go,
welcome dear bakery
hi, I'm very happy to be here,
thank you for the invitation, tell me
when I
was somehow there in local sports in the 90s, I was there, you were
n't in the company, no, there was, I'm
real  So if I was born in 72 and
now I'm 50 then I was in the 1990s doing my
degree in the department so
not yet in the company definitely by then
I was almost done
with my studies and
actually
with my husband in the world  on the road
who led a completely different life
and still leads a
professional show jumper, today the
national coach, so that was
probably the time in my life
when the company still
played a role, but
from a distance, so we are still
in all  been informed over the years
but were not
actively involved in any of the committees you are still very relevant in Essen with the
company of the largest people publishing houses
media houses
and
I am still no longer there and
you experience it every day but it was  being a
big employer was very present with you even
as a child, so to speak, your
parents have a publishing house, so you
said so and to be honest, I'm also
very happy to be able to talk to you about it
as someone who
also comes from Essen, because when you're in  If
Essen becomes big with a media company,
then that is certainly different from
Hamburg or Berlin. The Ruhr area
was also a region in the 1980s and 1990s
morning to evening
also played a role in our family
but it was
certainly much clearer to me
that owning a newspaper
is something different than a screw factory
if we
had a teacher in math lessons the Klara Schalke fan
so now Dortmund was clearly
not just ahead in terms of results  was but
also in the reporting, so then
you noticed that there was really
crass
the
whole, the whole
displeasure about how it was reported about what was
n't written about
that we already felt that
and it was for us
sometimes in our childhood
difficult to grow as much as
we grew up that was
relatively
sheltered in the sense of it just ca
n't just ride a bike to
Essen Altenessen because that just
wasn't so safe
a sister
and maybe for everyone who sparks now
Media doesn't mean that I
know from a distance
which titles were the biggest back then,
so I knew what and the NZ, so
regional newspapers, there was a whole
range of radio stations, radio participation,
what was there back then, what's
there now  We actually
started. Our grandfather founded
the WAZ together with Erich Bros. That was in
1945 right after the war,
originally in Bochum and then the
company very quickly settled in Essen. It
got bigger and
over the years the first
acquisitions were made  that was primarily the
Westfalenpost and the Westfälische
Rundschau in the 90s, together
with the NRZ and the Watz, by the way,
our
later stepfather and former
managing director together with the other
managing director Schumann already
invented the so-called watzmodel, which
means creating a synergy from four local newspapers
all
technical issues to manage the
editorial departments more or less independently and
particularly economically, that is,
what is now known as the major
synergy effects were
recognized and implemented relatively early on in the Ruhr area,
then of course there were radio stations that
came along, and then at some point at the end
of the
Then in the 1970s the first magazines came along with
Gong Verlag, then we
set up our own book publishing company,
Klartext-Verlag, which still exists today,
but it was really very lucky for us
Günther goodkamp, ​​already married to our mother,
brought home a pack of magazines
and these were just the current ones, so
everything that this great Gong publishing house
published at the time was also very
successful and said we
bought it, it was cheap but it has
now nothing to do with journalism
for Ms. Lobby Ms. Lobby was
our help at home for a long time and it was
already evident for someone like
him who was never a
media person because he just never
worked as a journalist but
really as
our grandfather's legal right hand
the company came along and after
the death of the grandfather, the
four daughters, my mother and her three
sisters, thought about who would run
the newspaper now because it was never
intended that one of the daughters
should become one,
so you can rely on him because he
basically had the best idea about the newspaper
and he just had one and that
was an incredibly clever
entrepreneurial instinct for suitable
acquisitions but the view is
journalistic today we are God glad
that we have such a
flourishing large magazine
segment that it really  the
reliable machine in the basement of our
rather big old tanker
and so
we started we have just
taken over great brands in the program and in the frost the
BILD der FRAU the Hörzu belongs to it we
have a big puzzle publishing house
we are actually leaders in Europe so all
these sudokus  program magazines come from us,
as I said, that was
basically the main driver for the
springer deal, that we
were able to grow so much in the program segment, of course, with the ones here,
how big we got,
interestingly enough, we were never allowed to read them before
the Springer deal, we had our
own one, you might know it  still from the
Watz there was such a supplement BWZ
quite a lot so really only program
instructions and pictures in black and white and
if we somehow brought the Hörzu
with us then it will be
thrown in the garbage immediately because that was from
Springer we can’t live with it  So it
was already clear that was has a lot
to do with what concerns me today in my
responsibility, namely this
clear view of entertaining
journalism somehow not
on a par with informative
journalism,
but then also very clearly these deep
rifts that were really cultivated in relation to
the others  Houses, so
springer products weren’t read
before something was sold where they would
rather be placed, so there was already
very pronounced cut-throat competition
and that also
shaped our childhood and youth a
bit
in the 80s 90s
there was one that
we of course also read when you
walked by the kiosk somewhere,
the octopus from the Ruhr area, so our
stepfather was very well known for
having what he wanted, then he had his
arm  long and if
the other side didn't
shout hurrah right away because that was just
another, a different understanding of
power that was lived out out of
strength,
that means already
obviously experienced what is
being built around you, so to speak,
and how  will then be your own path so
after graduating from high school what do you have to study then
I’m going to study right after graduating from high
school then by the way I
always did internships in other
media companies during my school days because, to be
honest, that’s why I was very fascinated by
what this media industry
actually is  because and that is
actually a part of my
story, but it is also the case that
our entire family came from Essen,
but because of the company and the
disputes that can also be read in the
press, this
whole family
broke up this whole family construct  and in the end
our own family too, so our
mother got
married um grootkamp as a second marriage,
my sister and I were ten and
14 or 39 um Niklas, our eldest
brother five years older and of course
that moved me a lot, not just
personally
to grow up in an environment where
not from one day to the next but
relatively soon realizes that this very
close family bond that
existed also among the sisters
is broken because of the fact that
all of a sudden a lot of initiatives
have an impact from outside and the
sisters  then
did the worst with each other, namely
breaking off contact with each other, and with it
the management and their responsibility
for the newspaper for what had to be
transferred to lawyers and
authorized representatives at the time, and
I experienced just as much as my
siblings how our
mother had to carry an incredible burden
in the end, however, by marrying
her managing director, i.e. the person
responsible for the Funke side,
my mother of course
really created security for
the company on the one hand, I am
still convinced that it
was also a great love, Mr. Gotham  is now
yes yes well I saw him above all
very early
almost
24/7 at home or is that
not true because he actually left before we
came to breakfast and
only came when we
had already finished dinner like that  really this
typical generation of managers, of course, there were
also vacationers together, but
what somehow fascinated me was to
subordinate his whole life to a task, so he
really burned for the Watts,
then he really has his fax machine and
everything  I have to take it with me and then
the infinitive was rebuilt in France
and he just kept
working there and I found that
fascinated me and I wanted to know more
about the industry, so internships
during school in many other
houses,
which was interesting there too  Mr.
Gotham
also wanted to open all kinds of doors for me.
I think the mistake was a
bit that the door was not only opened
by
calling some publisher's boss, but he
always took me there.
Westdeutsche Zeitung Wuppertal I remember
I came  on the first day and he
brought me to the editorial office I've
always said you don't have to I like to
go alone because I knew for sure I'd
experienced it twice before then you'll just be
handed over there and so that Julia and  she's
supposed to learn something here for four weeks
and from then on no one
spoke to me anymore.
Editorial conferences always took
place without me and I was allowed
to make coffee once, so that
was the Watz back then and
I noticed that it was really a real one  A big
player who, above all,
I think has a lot of edges because of its size and also because of
a certain droning potential, so
I think this
image and that was one of the things I
experienced and after I graduated from high school I
went straight to Munich  I
did an internship at the Süddeutsche Landesstudio and that
was actually a very cool time
because I couldn’t go there because
it was Munich in the RTL Landesstudio in
Munich I also did an internship for three four months
and was always
responsible for the traffic reports
for RTL Aktuell that was the new
news format different time no
longer on the hour let alone
at 8 o’clock in the evening and everything was a
bit more boulevard desk lurid
so I was supposed to accompany the accidents on the
A9 with the camera and that was
often the case  Also,
always listen to the feedback as a police radio
and if the pictures we
brought with us weren’t really
bloody, then it’s a pity Julia,
we imagined it differently,
unfortunately we can’t see it, so that
was the first one, it was like that  the first
points of contact and because I was
with RTL in Cologne at the time, our
company still had a ten percent
stake in RTL,
the stake was of course very
worthwhile when we sold it, there
were zero synergy effects today it would
do something different but there moving images and
also  So this type of
news journalism was
simply an
investment, a cash contribution and also
not in any form already
strategically thought ahead that you
could somehow develop two news formats together
recorded exactly I then only
studied German and English
Theater Studies in Munich
but I only did that because  I
thought it was really cool and Munich Schwabing a bit
too,
so Theater Studies I
've always
tried to not stray a bit from the path to the
left and right
but to see what else
is there then I
switched to Münster and then I  I
finished my studies by the time I got my master’s degree,
then politics also added to that
and yes, and then
basically because of the proximity
to Essen I was a bit more physically involved again.
I was then also more intensively
involved with the publishing house but
I think  I needed my
childhood in Essen after this special time
and I think I really needed it
I never went back
to Essen until today so a little
now you live I think
somehow all around Münster no exactly I we
live with the family in one of these
small village near Munster it is an
hour’s drive to Essen and the publishing house
but I can also be
in Berlin in two and a half hours so this
distance is actually optimal for me
I noticed after a time
in Munich that I have a lot of things it’s
very often like that  you have to go away first
in order to come back and that was
an important time for me to gain experience in
the industry. Above
all, I got to know many of these
publishers who are no longer so active.
Up until then, our contacts were
n't enough because that's a little bit
special story Mr. Gotham wanted to
buy the Bild newspaper very early on
and
then there was a very well
we
always go to Juist during the summer holidays so always
earlier all the
whole family always to Juist also always
like six weeks summer holidays
stream after rain that's how you
remember it, of course it wasn't like that, but
in this little house on Juist there was
actually a call
where my mother wants to be so phone
still and the area answered and
answered and then on the
other end was
Friede Springer and  said that the
WAZ is unfortunately out of the question as a
buyer and a few years many years
later there was
another call from Friede
Springer on this very phone where she informed my mother
that they would be ready to offer her
quite extensive
print portfolio  to sell us
very big deal for both
Springer and for you at that time it was
a lot of attention you
then bought this other newspaper from the
Abendblatt in Hamburg and so on top of it
and just what you just
meant somehow listen to it and so um but
okay it  means you somehow
came back near the publishing house when you made the detour Munich via the Munich distance and then at
some point you felt okay I'm
needed there I'm the next generation
I have to somehow take on a role now
how did that happen  first of all
you have to say that in the
years we had three children my
brother Niklas is a lawyer in Essen my
sister nora has two younger children
than mine so my eldest daughter is
21 we of course somehow
used this time after graduation to
to start families, our mother
always gave us the time and freedom to
build up our lives, so to speak, there was never a deadline
when she said I was expecting a
colon or, as in other publishers,
the courses were even specified
so that everyone was trained more or less the same
and in the end,
one of four decides who
does it or who wasn't with us,
it was clear that our mother and
Günter groot came into this company in
her role, so there were four
families and my mother was
very involved with him
in the  Verlag a completely different
affiliation for her as the youngest of
four sisters than it was originally
intended for you,
so our grandfather could never have
imagined that a girl
would follow in his footsteps and he
struggled a lot too and our mother
as the youngest always did  very much
wished and the only thing he
then offered her was a secretary
job at WAZ and I am telling you this
because it has a lot to do with
how we women but maybe
I also have to do my role again today with
a different responsibility  but
definitely also experience emotions because
she never got out of this secretary role
as long as her grandfather was
alive and funnier
actually not funny at all, but when
Jakob Funke died and Günter became
his successor, a
lot has changed, but that’s just it  not the
role of our mother, so she stayed
when he was
Günter's secretary, but that was what
she
accepted for you and
naturally worked her way more and more into the
company through this task  and
then luckily
found a way with Mr grothkamp to do it together, what
I mean to say by that, in the
years that we had our children,
our mother
litigated intensively against her sisters for almost ten years and that was the
only way  and just about the
distributions
of the company so there is a
family contract and it says that so
and so many percent
must be distributed to the
shareholders our mother always
said it was possible was certainly never in
our grandfather’s interest and we have to
invest and we  should only or
should only
distribute what should not flow into the company
for new investments and so on and
their
sisters had a different opinion and that's
why there were simply these ten almost
ten very intensive years where the
sisters only litigated against each other with one
and  the company
was virtually incapable of action because
of course
no really relevant
decisions could be made at the operational level
because at some point it happened
that if one said yes,
the other said no on principle
and then what a time that was
incredibly dangerous for that  The
company was also a matter of
managerial staff because
of course they were also able to implement relatively few of the things
that would have been necessary
and when I returned to the
publishing house it was in a situation so
we are my brother and I then
at some point I think around 2012 in the in
the shareholders' committee and the
supervisory board
were practically appointed by our mother,
but that was after the acquisition
of the Prost shares, that was in 2012,
so she bought the shares of the
co-owning family ten years ago, the
mutual suing, there was always a
blockage, exactly
our mother said at some point we
will be like this  drive the company up against the wall
if we don't
create clear conditions in some form, we
block ourselves so we can't come to a
decision and the company is
no longer able to act and then
the death of the publisher gave rise to
the possibility for all of these breast that
our mother  basically
made an offer to their grandchildren and
took over their shares so we then had
66.6 percent in the Watt, it
was then
called the Funke Media Group in the same year,
simply to make it clear that it is
now a family company and the
Founder Jakob Funke should be our face,
what we as a family business
will be like in the future,
our grandfather, her father, who, as I said,
hasn't noticed so little over the years and unfortunately didn't realize that
his youngest daughter
was the one who did so much for that
company has also managed to
change what kind of company talk to
at that time to a bigger, I
mean, as I see it,
it was always such a giant
group, now today you know it makes more
than a billion in sales, then
you would, well, I suppose  that was
already an evaluation back then, it must have been in the area,
so clearly, above
all, at a time when
sales and marketing revenues were just
bubbling up, so there
was no need for them, because the
journal did the marketing
financed journalism and without a newspaper, without a
magazine, no advertisements at that time the
world was still fine, I would
say,
so the valuation for this deal was
certainly
set correspondingly high and
rightly so, because the company was in excellent health
at that time, there was already the
Braunschweiger Zeitung wir  had
already acquired the titles in Thuringia, so
we have three newspapers in Thuringia,
there is a monopoly, there was a
magazine portfolio and the
difference to our
sibling transaction, which we
may come to later in 2021,
our mother actually financed it from
her private assets, so
no bank  nobody
and so we had invested a large part of the
family business in our
own shop
and not and that was also
very special for me when we
ourselves as siblings now
took over the final last shares it was too  I never
thought at the time that a company was supposed to
pay it back, so it wasn't a
loan or it was simply a clear
understanding that we had to do something to
resolve these stalemate situations because
that was the only way to
shake things up again and then
relatively quickly two years  later in 2014
to implement the Springer Deal,
you published
about a billion more for
Springer's magazine and newspaper portfolio, so if we're paying a
lot of money for everything,
that's exactly what you're paying in cash, of course, with the
banks that have accompanied us, but it  it was
clear that the family is the one
that makes its contribution, um, the size
on the market is the other thing that
will give uncertainty and that's why Springer Deal
therefore also liabilities
where it was very clear to us that we were
n't in any way up to that point, so the premise of
our grandfather and you  So you come from
making Essen nice or being unemployed
or that was really crap
and
it would have
been irresponsible from a business point of view to say we do
n't do that or we're
just trying to continue to act a bit in the old
entrepreneurial way of thinking  There was
time for that, there are
banks, we did really well with it,
but
it was really discussed a lot, it was
almost 10 years
ago now, looking back, it would make us normal,
so at Springer we are
still, I think everyone is of the same opinion  it
was good that they sold because
Springer's path out of one of the worlds
leads out of the classic
media,
so to speak, I assume they
'll do it again if you
ask them, yes
it's quite interesting that we asked the
question  because I was three
weeks four weeks ago I think with Mr.
Scholz and he asked me exactly the same question
and at the end of the
conversation he said if you
do a springer deal again and I can
really convince you more deeply and
not because I  I have a
PR story to tell here
because we have achieved exactly what
we set out to do, namely size,
security on the market, we have really grown from a
Ruhrpott company into a
major media player, the
magazine portfolio has
grown endlessly, but it is also important for what
we do  as a media company, we have set ourselves the goals
of society,
of social relevance,
but also towards the mission, so
we understand our publishers do
really pluralistic there vote in
our society
we have set ourselves that and I
can also say one thing, the planning  that
we did back then, despite
a lot of things that didn’t work either,
harmonization of such large,
so large and very
different editorial departments
didn’t work in the
most ambitious two years, so we
always do the Funkes and the
Springers together and then it works for me
I think that in the greater culture shock, especially
for the employees
who came to us from Springer,
there was probably not one in the entire
industry I remember,
so we then thought after
as I said that called one billion
that was really a big one  Deal and
I can't remember that in the
media industry in
Germany, after or before that,
what was sold on the same scale
and then we still thought we
'd have a nice welcome party in
Essen at Bauer kammerzeit
discussed so decorated not discussed for a long time
because we  just wanted to
eat is just our home that's where
we come from and that's why
I think on straw bales and that was in
the fall it was a couple of pumpkins and
then the gentlemen came and they
forgive me for that because I've seen
them very often  raised it
then a delegation from Hamburg came
rushing up they really had
their white silk scarves on
because they probably thought there was a
big philharmonic orchestra happening here
or
a bottle of beer in your hand and you
noticed that
being sold a bit is really bitter I
know  but fortunately and I do
n't mean that in a disrespectful way we did it
out of conviction because we
also wanted to offer these brands a home,
certainly a little
more down-to-earth and less chic and
fewer window axes and less noise
at the
Christmas celebrations, but
everything is a little more
normal with us  also nice also comfortable
and I think that today many of the
people have understood what we
were about, namely preserving the brands
certainly amazing energy effects
not important for us above all the
digital know-how of the people who
came to us from Springer has us
Insanely well done and the
Hamburger Abendblatt Berliner Morgenpost brands
we are incredibly proud of,
as well as for how to
remember the magazine portfolio is of course in preparation. There
are still around 300
million debts from the deal,
so you still have to pay 300 million after 10
years  You pay back step by step
from the transaction precisely
because we have also made a plan,
we have
not presented it to ourselves and said in
half a year we will have
earned it again easily and I think that
we are very good with the banks too
drove us, it is also attested
that we really lived up to our story
despite crises and
despite many and that was
probably
the greatest challenge of all
if you asked would you do the jumper
again
it was actually much more difficult to
implement everything internally  what you have
planned really these blockages
in the heads we then grew to
six locations throughout Germany
and no longer just one
in Braunschweig eats a Thuringia so
this large portfolio also in terms of
employee culture to
harmonize and also to
break down borders where the  magazine area does
n't say so that it's ours here that
isn't shared with the newspapers
so this whole topic of
synergy effects from content sharing, which
we've honestly been asking for two or
three years now,
nobody has really implemented that until then, everyone has one
made a bit more and then
at some point I think it was the first
high builder we are now a huge
group and then you do two or three
years you work on your plans and
then you start to falter somewhere and
then you need someone really good
for the job  for the
company and for the brands to
dig as deep as possible to be able to conduct this type of
journalism economically
and when it starts
to hang a bit and that's what happened to us
then holes open up and there are also
differences that need to be bridged
again it cost you a lot of time and
money because your
journey has to be traced a bit in parallel,
so you are then,
so to speak, in the that was then so
probably the early 10 years more
the company Range moves and then
also as you as a family
took over won a bit of
the chairmanship of the supervisory board although
that came later officially 2019
I think no yes 20 18 exactly so my
youngest daughter was born in 2016 and I
always had a bit of a
goal that when she might be 16 17 18
then it would be ideal because
then we are  three children almost out of the
woods we live in the country
and we made a conscious decision at the time,
my husband, as I said, a
show jumper, travels a lot around the world,
we are always a bit part of this
traveling circus until the children go
to school at some point
went and then it just can't
go to the horse shows anymore it's a
world-class rider you're that far too
so it was honest quite honestly it
was a bit of the Jopi Heesters
effect I thought that before
I found my husband great when  I
saw him riding on television in Aachen
I got autographs from what
is because he always
passed by and so I didn’t
get that many autographs from him either, but
I really thought he was
very good
as a fan for a long time and at some point I had  we
really got to know each other better and we
are all very enthusiastic in my family, so
that's how my
parents got to know each other, but
of course as a hobby and um after
I moved my husband together with it,
I went to him in Paul's stable
Schockemöhle followed and that's
sort of the Mecca of the riding elite and
I also had a horse like that,
but it's more like a
Golf, I had a very simple, loyal,
very nice horse and he
could do it for me too
he did everything he wanted, but there
were obstacles at that level,
we wouldn't be able to
get over them and no one was that
interested, so unfortunately
my husband didn't find them all either, so
I'm here with my pony farm
Flair made a big contribution, so
it was really a different world that
I got into, which
was good because it had a lot to do with the fact
that I
found my way around there and that the children
were there in this kind of surrounding
because the media and what and food
didn't play any role at all and that gave me security because
I was there, so to speak, I didn't have a label on my
head and I was able to do
a little bit
but
really as a hobby rider and I think I
have so many other strengths that I can  The good thing is
I can organize logistical
things I can
organize stables. I still do that today,
but I am keen on horseback riding and the funny thing
is my children, of
course I told them that a bit differently,
so I hope they don't hear it, but
I have  said successes so they
were more as high as the table
here I was quite safe but that was
nothing where I
am the father so one they are all three
very very good are all also
show jumpers and unfortunately it is inevitable
that they  Of course,
they don't just go horseback riding through the woods, but
they do show jumping as a
real passion, which they practice very intensively.
Unfortunately, it's not like
hockey that you have a stick
that you then
put in the corner  but we have
around 30 horses at home and they have to be
very well organized, of course,
we have to make hay, make
electricity, order feed, so it
's a real business that
's not as romantic as you might
imagine, but it had work, so
to speak  next to the company then
you can make the decision so okay I'm going
to the company now and you have
n't had any classic commercial
training in advance, so to speak, or a deep, say
media media management, yes, you
've experienced that for years from afar
and all your youth
spent in the media environment but
then you first have to find your way
into such a company and its
managing directors and such or was that
very natural for you or was it something
completely new to suddenly have such responsibility
for billions of companies as
someone who never  now operationally
managed is already a word exactly
so first of all the time then
relatively that
came in the spring when
we had planned it in the family
so
how you plan to do it is one thing,
our stepfather then actually became
very demented, very much  quickly very demented so
that our mother decided
she wants to, who was
on the supervisory board before me, she would like to
hand it over earlier,
so my husband your father, the stepfather,
who can’t do that anymore, you have to
do it now, yes, she didn’t call,
it was for  the three of us siblings
you only know Niklas so we are
very very close and of course you experience that
in the family that the
time how we planned to do it all
or how you also
discuss it I also always planned to
like me, for example  sit down and then
he wanted to tell me everything about our
industry, about the contracts, how you
do it with the ippens and how it works in Cologne
and it never came to that because
he just jumped through bronchitis in such a quick way
and
so  he then became so demented very quickly
that he simply didn’t
know anything about what I would have loved to hear
he could tell me for the three of us it
was clear at some point you ca
n’t ask a mother to
choose one of the three of us, my
siblings will be the same
Niklas as a lawyer
before me also on the shareholders' committee
Mr goodkamp also as a lawyer or
due to his legal competence so
he was
certainly a bit younger in the committees and still
had small children but they could have
done it just as well but we  then
we thought about it and then we really
arranged to meet up for an afternoon and said
we have to find a solution now who
will be from the three of us
and
that is when you are close and also know
like the others what their expectations are and how
they plan their lives
not easy
to find a way that allows everyone to
deal with and live with how it is then and how it has become afterwards
without you having the feeling that there
is someone now so what are you to me
that's okay here I would  I'm already happy to
go out here and then
take on the task or I
know that I'm good at one thing and that's
really
the responsibility as well as I said
it's the same for Nora Niklas,
but I always knew I could do it, even if
you were right  tell me I was missing
all the
stuff about studies about any
semesters abroad, wherever I
really saw it from childhood,
loved to experience what happens,
so also strikes and situations like
that where you just grow into
my studies were certainly not the
best preparation, although important for
yes  Everything that is also journalistic is
probably totally dispensable according to
my feeling, so now,
with a few years of entrepreneurial
experience, you do the day-to-day yourself, that's the
fault and then you should
probably have the experience and
then maybe that's still missing and you
need it and that  is perhaps the
difference to other
media companies, we are a strategic company as a
supervisory board and shareholder committee,
which
means that of course we always have a management for all
tax issues, legal issues,
entrepreneurial i.e. operational issues,
that is also
their responsibility, that means a
degree in business administration would not have
helped me either, but on  At the end of the day, you have to
rely on the fact that the team
you have there that
strategically and operationally manages the company and is
strategically controlled by us, that they
are reliably really the best for
this job after
we three siblings then
agreed on one like me today  I
still think it's a wonderful way
because my siblings made it very easy for me,
maybe they felt that I wanted it the
most, I think you can
say that I
was perhaps most willing to devote my life so much to that,
not because that
somehow bored at home or
wasn't enough but
because I always felt and knew
I was preparing for it and my
children were the way they grew up
that was
actually the ideal setting for me I
was somehow ready to do it and  how
much but that is currently so if you
now imagine there are
also supervisory board members, I have
the feeling from afar that it is
not a full-time job in the sense or that
is not even half-time or did
you already have less  Deployment
in case of doubt
as it is with you, so you are already
busy with it every day or or I mean
in the end it is also so that one of
you is also heard of you,
the company belongs to you, so if it works for the
wall then you are the ones affected
or  if things go well then you are
the ones who get the exhibition,
so how do you live it
very intensively when I started in 2018, firstly through the
preparation, we then engaged in
a
workshop, so to speak, on the supervisory board that I
initiated with my siblings
together we said we're going to do
a workshop now and want to
think about how we want to
work together with the committee in the future the
minority shareholders still had
their representatives there
so there were members in this committee
where
where the question was simply how
intense we want to be here
work together in addition to what
the management does and the old
mode, which I also noticed from my
previous years in the group of shareholders,
was that you
somehow meet three times a year, we
then increased it to four at some point,
then the management writes
an annual report for three hours  before so really
frontal teaching they stand in
front you sit here is the slice
then at some point a decision will
be made but you have zero
impossibility to
look critically afterwards or follow up
because everything that was just a very
one-sided information channel the
documents you
get as a group of shareholders  you
provided the management and
logically it only said what you
should see, so the dirty corners,
um, they were actually gladly left
out and this workshop in
2018 we had from the committee,
so the supervisory board commissioned a consultation, so
a status quo  a look
at our company, including
management, is always
originally linked to the question of how do
we actually want to be here in the future,
how intensively do we want to take care of it,
is everything good, where are we all at the moment,
or
is it important that we possibly
Thinking some areas differently and in a new way
and what I can say I mean that is
also the topic of advice is more relevant
than ever if you look at other houses
I think the difference
we made back then was to commission this
advice from the
group of shareholders that
was at least  I know few
publishing houses that hold up a mirror to their management where the owners do that,
and I think
the management also thought of us
as the next generation, but also
maybe quite specifically of me as a
young woman,
now here comes her with her very
brisk  The idea would like to do something new
and the feeling was somehow like that,
the first three months they thought it was
right, so they always said great, it’s
going really well and the advice
was all such a nice idea but
probably turned around and thought yes
and then we’ll do it all please  again
as before
the project was groundbreaking for us
because we really looked into the deepest
depths of our company
and in the end the
project ended
with the realization that we
really have an economically
blatantly large gap that we
operationally but urgently fill  I
can also say that because our
understanding as a family
towards our banks is really also here, that's how
we grew up, so whoever has
debts is currently paying them
back quickly and we can't
afford not to do any things here
because someone  because
otherwise his reporting lines no longer
have, but we really have to do
the best we can,
so we have to position ourselves entrepreneurially in such a way
that double structures and
everything that is just as up-to-date today
as it was then
must not lead to every
result-securing measure by the
editors always leading  then when things
are determined in January,
perhaps everything is not going
so well at first and then the first thing you look
at is the editorial office because there are
enough people there and we wanted to
stop that for the long term. Do you believe that managing
directors are fundamentally different
today than when they  The core question
is also a podcast, now
I have to ask it, so when we talk about
newspapers and magazines, of course, there are
now a lot online, um,
offshoots or online products, but
basically the magazine
still does it
next for the next five
so far feel good so
that's actually quite a since it's getting down
to business
I ask one thing above all that
we as a family don't run this company
in order to
have the best possible financial success we
try to run this company in such a way
that  it is entrepreneurially
able to finance our journalism,
which nowadays
no longer runs automatically
through marketing and sales revenues
as we had in the 80s 90s
we have now arrived in a digital
world where this excess of
information is exactly what we are  this this
unique selling proposition and this
exclusivity news sovereignty
no longer has any claim
to
market leadership in
advertising spending so there are just so
many big players
just the giants Amazon Google
really took our
proceeds with bucket wheel excavators
if you ask me now
think  I believe in the business model, yes, I
believe that we
still have to see infinite added value in the fact that there will
always be people
who will also pay money for sustainable, reliable journalism it is important
that you can rely on the source
and that in a world like
this  where classification but also
reflections objective representation is
more important than ever we
have to be the ones who say we pay
our journalists that they
really do their job in the sense of the
press code of reasonable
and I believe the added value is
journalism is certainly still
there if  we'll make it
and that's a bit where
I'm always a bit in
conflict, thank God Mr. gotkamp
certainly recognized the future of the
magazines of entertaining
journalism for our
company early on he had no
technical vision where where do
we want to
no one went to America with our editorial system and took a
look at how they work
there and and isn't it so this time
looking outside the box
at the end these job exchanges go online
and Springer is helping a lot no that's the way it
is with this StepStone and
all of these are going very well there, so
you could say that in hindsight,
man, we could have done that too,
or fortunately we did it,
so in the years
after the Springer Deal 20 18 was
my time, as I said  we take care
of ourselves a little bit for a year,
so we really have to
ask ourselves how intensively
we care, so then there came
a time when we saw that we had to
care a lot more and since then
I think the self-image in the
committee has also been there  Then the management was
replaced because from then on it was
always about the question of how
we will earn our money in the future
and I think the biggest
problem back then in 2018 as now is a
self-image in the heads of the
managers who are sitting there for an amazing salary  Up to
this point it has actually always
been enough, so who really
wants
to think five years ahead and
develop new business models? That's what we have to do now,
but out of a
great pressure situation because
one or the other has already done so  runs
out of breath or he says I don’t think so
anymore and sells titles that are
actually still bringing a good result,
so we’ve certainly
made one at Funke, we
spent many important years with it, unfortunately,
because we were always arguing internally about
the strategy  so we have a
how do we deal with our dividends
that was the time of our mother
then
restructuring of the group that was
when I started in 2018
such a mindset so a change
in our heads what we
thought was necessary we can’t
seriously  the editorial departments that
continue to be put out on the
grounds that there are still enough seats
because our journalistic
substance creativity is dumped overboard with every
other journalist dismissed,
always with the focus on optimizing the result,
this is
also something like that  little manager think so
from the 80s 90s maybe
how Mr. got comes that lived and
the love for the journalistic brands
I felt at least when I
looked at our company
in almost none of those or yes
the really the really big
You had responsibility at the management levers if you now look at the numbers
and now you can also
read that I wo
n’t reveal a whole one here now makes about an
annual profit of around 80 90 million in the
last few years, of course, it’s also a difficult year,
of course, despite that you the  biggest,
even if you were to try it now,
difficult to say, but if it were like that,
mostly in Mama 10, then the company would be
worth 800 million, that's
of course when you see that he paid
a billion for not too long ago
for the  the very very
springer package maybe a
loss in value, at least temporarily,
yes, although I believe, as I said,
company valuation, we just have
everything behind us in that
my siblings and I then
decided in 2021 to also
take over the remaining shares, we
already have a lot  very intensively over many
months with the value of our
company and the question
is simply what what is this
company for us and it is simply
a
journalistic house and not a
screw factory that means
operating in such a way that we are independent
and only then is it independent
being able to do independent free journalism is our job have
a blatant statement so I find it
impressive and somehow also
enthusiastic that you say well how do we
optimize here now not for the
profit or for the distribution or for
the company value the
sharing yes also longing for an eye on it
or that also
lowers it in the sense of
social responsibility,
so maybe I'm not telling you that
here because I somehow think it's
a nice story,
but because in the end it always revolved around it in our
discussions with our
fellow partners  At
some point in the first
lockdown we noticed our plan, which is
then presented to you, it
may not be achieved in this way and the
first reflex and I found that
remarkable was then we now have to take
measures to secure the result and then
we are back to what we were
20  Years ago we somehow found the only
solution to lay off staff,
then our claim was always to say
if we don't achieve this result,
okay, we have banks that simply
present our plans
to them, but also explain that it is
necessary to
forego distributions to restructure the company
really what
this family of ours, no matter how complex
it may be, consists of people who
are the core family, that's us and
others who somehow came along,
we all lived incredibly well in these years thanks to
Watz and Funke
and we were very early
of the opinion and that was
our mother's decision back in 2012 it is
now up to us to give something back to this company, that's
why we
put our family assets into it and
not as payback, the company
now has debts to the
gutkamp family and we would have liked to have
paid them back one day  and I still do
n't understand to this day that the reflex
is now one crisis after the
other
and at the same time we notice every day,
especially in the first lockdown, that the
relevance, the systemic relevance of our
information, this reliability of the
brands, but also the trust in
entertainment like  many people sat old
people in the lockdown in waiting rooms
in old people's homes no one came to
visit me anymore
and they were happy when
there was a current woman or a
woman who was three weeks old lying in the mirror
because that's it  this entertainment, which
a large part of our society
knows and is used to, and possibly
even sometimes and that's sad as the
only piece of
information that is so familiar,
naturally
becomes smaller and smaller, so it worries me
that you can, that's a process that
you can't  above all, I think it's
incredibly important
not to target this target group in print
and that bothers me when titles
are sold these days that simply
have a great circulation because there are
people who have a subscription 2030 years
and those are exactly the people who
help us now to finance the digital transformation
and my claim is
simply to take care of it at Funke
okay we have liabilities that
we will serve there is no
question but it takes so much more
creativity in the minds of
managers
to do this task  and
when I look at Funke it's
no secret when I say we sat
there with articles of incorporation in which
80% of the
company's earnings had to be distributed
and this
clause which our mother
had been fighting for years and she didn't  to change was that has
that has caught up with us and the company
in a completely different dimension in the
first place women because if you
say at some point people now
we have to replan and underwrite but
you can also rightly say with
shareholders who say yes but that
company is still there in ten years time
the distribution is due to us so
hear a love or an
appreciation for a company which is
first of all something factual or what
is now purely on paper that is
almost philosophical what is a
company so you can  somehow value a company
in the end the money in the
account is the safe bank and
you can somehow then I know not
just sell the apartment but
make very safe investments or just
keep the cash in the account or
buy gold yes I
decided against you  you really have
a certain, maybe even part of
your rational love and and and
sense of responsibility towards a
company that
has no feelings and doesn't
expect any responsibility now, but you
even played anyway, so
first of all we play this
responsibility for all the people who
work for us and I think that is
a next point that is
also becoming so audible and noticeable these days, there
are people who know they are not
secure in their job this is
certainly the case in many other industries
and certainly also in many
areas  von Funke we will
no longer be able to afford this type of staff in some areas of Funke
simply because
digitization is a process that
cannot be stopped and
responsibility for the employees is
one responsibility for such a
large company you  somehow we
always have to think about how we can do it
as a family despite our we ended
up investing three times in our own
company with our
mother, so to speak, then the Springer deal came and
now we have siblings who have
completed this mission and so
the other one does  the last shareholders
who did not buy out the
company is now for the first time in its
75-year history what will be
75 this year in the hands of a family
and knowing this certainty we do
not need to discuss how there will be
no more discussions about the
future of Funke  When it comes to leading this
regional journalism but also
this large
magazine portfolio into a future
because our aim is
to run the company so economically
that we can afford it and
my siblings and I are certainly
not going to be dead in sacks and
ashes but it is  there are no distributions
there are no distributions in the form
as they were intended and that we
always had to make because there was
simply no other
way legally and
I feel when you say it's a
bit like you called it like
I'm irrational again  I find this to be deeply
rational because it is the
most meaningful thing I
can imagine to
make a contribution to providing people with reliable information, especially in these
times,
and
to securing a job and
making sure that
people are reasonably safe even in times of crisis  how we
all get through and I don't think that's a
question at all I think the
attitude is great at the same time,
of course, living in the world where it
has to be economically sound in some way and in the end that that's sad for some people,
even for his attitude there
isn't one yet  Gratitude and then
people still go and say, man,
I would have liked to continue,
but it just can't be done, or
the economy doesn't know anyone, how
should you say that, no mercy,
so it's only very rarely or not
to the extent where it's necessary
Companies
to keep Princess running, so what I experienced in my
very early days as an intern in the industry
is that it is
an incredibly egocentric
industry, so where many more
personal agents play a role
and this visibility and that is
belief  I also today our problem that
this industry still likes to frolic so much in such
a
cut-throat battle
I do believe that there are many
things that we
could and should do better together to help
smaller publishers but also
larger ones in partnerships  To offer
security in order to maintain brands after brands
and to continue editorial work freely and
independently so much
technical stuff you can really
do together and what bothers me is that we
are apparently still not doing so
badly that one does not feel the need
badly about the other  talk
but to say let's do something together
or a family like
all of us so maybe you've
noticed how
much people like to discuss me that
maybe has to do with the fact that as a
woman I'm still somehow a
bit of an alien  I'm but I've had
little
positive feedback and also
received support from the industry
from a few but in the majority
this big deal that can only go badly
Springer deal that can only go wrong but
it isn't and it won't be
yes  actually quite
astonishing because that has already been
mentioned by many jumpers who at least
your mother had something to do with and I
assume you too and then there
is the man in the background at the end
of the moon the company in the
family so now you with  the larger
German media companies, the largest,
are then even if you have women who
do it, so there's no such
connection. So do you know this month
or do you talk to her or Friedrich
Springer or did it all
fall asleep so it never woke up
I would  say and the difference is
and I think you can
understand that I actually
grew up in a publishing family it
might make a difference whether
you marry someone more completely and then
carry on his legacy or whether
you take part of a
permit with your mother's milk
or not and  we are
possibly also a bit
different from the publishing families you
mentioned
because our mother us and of course our
father our parents too we were
brought up very down to earth you
also come from Essen so they
help out there and he sits  no one is
somehow on the sidelines and watches, but
the claim is to
do your part, however it
works,
and in that respect I would say I have
no contact with this publisher
because, to be honest, they
have never spoken to me like that, but I can understand
what  I am happy when
others, especially
in the last few weeks, there has also been
a lot
about the topic of women in the media and
equal rights and not just
women but all sorts of
migration backgrounds or backgrounds
that we are really there  don't
maneuver ourselves into a corner where we
spread such a closed shop atmosphere we have to
become more diverse we don't just have to present ourselves as a
pr-story but we really have to
make sure that when I
took the train here today so if
you look  which people sit in a
normal train compartment and you
compare that with a local editorial office
then there is a huge difference and
I don't understand the logic of that
because we actually have to depict everything that
depicts this society
in our editorial departments, so
if we're surprised  because you are addressing
exactly the topic where do
our new revenue models come from when the
preserver and the heritage are managed and
the free democratic contribution
and one thing is necessary you can
certainly be there in five years I also have
children my sister who will be the children
who also say thank you and say yes, but
how do we earn so much money that we
can run this company and that
requires new revenue models and, above
all, you
really need a good digital strategy, so
we are there in the regional media with
the subscription model  there was a
number called out by Christoph Rüth,
our managing director, one million
subscribers in 2025 and half of them
digital, I would then add another two years
and then we will also be
economically so imprell, i.e. in the
media in the regional media area,
that we say
can we have
managed this transformation phase from the print
subscription to the digital world and then
we will certainly also have in the
digital area we have what you
mentioned earlier with StepStone we
already bought various
jobcluster Job local
trainee ABSOLVENTA in 2012 and will become
one  Jobportfolio
merged The offices in Munich
are called Funke works and if you
enter them at kununu, they are a segment of
Funke where the ratings are top, where the
people are satisfied, where you simply
look at a digital business, which we are
really good at, so all these
job acquisitions, of course  Also
due to the pandemic, Funke is an
incredibly successful
company in the digital area,
so we actually have
holdings. Last year we
bought go feminar Musterhaus and Meder digital companies that
are close to our core business, which we
will then develop further just as feminar  there will
be a huge, huge new segment at Funke in the women's area there will be
the first events in autumn,
so we will start a new
event format, especially in the area
of ​​empowering women, these are
small businesses, such an event, I mean,
I'm already that myself  is of course
despite everything compared to what's out
there now, let's just say, it's a well-
scalable daily newspaper with a subscription and
everything that's different, I think the
key will be that you also know about
these many small
events and and there's certainly so
much more in the
health sector  we have now had the
picture of the woman's health day in Essen
picture of the woman sitting here in
Hamburg the health day with many
experts on the subject of women's health took place
in Essen that's
a giant step for Funke because it
's almost in a new place in our new
chic headquarters you  you know what
everything is clear
Place oh really it's Jakob from
place 1 and it's supposed to be you
told me that that's why I'm always happy because
nobody knows it's also a
piece of coal this building the
black big one that's Essen Cinemaxx
down there  Weststadt
hope they have it, but they have
drawn the line from mining regions
to
media companies of the future, joking
aside, these small events are
all small plants, but that's exactly what
we have to do now and that does
n't mean that it won't be there in five years  are
successful i am above
all of the opinion many
small speed boats do us a lot
so not to do that would be
irresponsible our core competence
is
regional journalism maintain
journalism women
program guides country titles we
have great new ones if you have a unity
in hamburg spark when there will be a
wonderful one  it's called the Collector's
Edition these are so royal issues for Queen
there's a great sustainability that
costs 10 euros you can buy it from Amazon
or at the train station trade these are
small runs in the past you probably would
n't have had a run of 200,000 that
the printing press is running today
we have editions of 20 to 30,000, but
it is important in so many areas,
including the food area,
to open up new ones and I just think that
our our market our industry
no longer needs one thing and these are these
1000 metho products, that's the way it is  a
relic from that time when you really
just tried to trick the other person
somehow so there
is
a section in the magazine area where
I'll name
a title will then become a Lena that will
do well in a publishing house  then
five me too products made by other
publishers that look exactly like that, they
are then called Lina Lea Lia so the customer and they are
often these older ladies on the
supermarket shelf which is now somehow three
meters 80 long and 4.10 high they are
actually  she does
n't think she wants to buy her problems anymore and to be honest I think that's the
way it's written off and
I don't want to exclude us at all
but that's one that's also what devalues ​​this
whole quality overall on a
magazine shelf, of course,
because then it's there  ten metho products
for a 70-cent booklet you do
n't really like each other either, that's why there's
really tough competition and if
that's the case here in Hamburg, there are the
colleagues from Bauer who are also active in the
segment where you're having
fun, I thought  to Yvonne Bauer
she is actually a young woman
or a young woman as well as
not a very young woman but there is no
relationship either but we know each other we know
each other above all
through the riding
I think it's not like that either
fighting this kind of rifts that's
certainly not what connects me with Yvonne
Bauer I think
especially in times of paper shortage and
I'm saying that here now quite openly
and honestly and certainly
also at Funke editors who are sitting
exactly on these issues with this one
order are on the way and
earn great money for us from the logic I have to
say at this point we
have to think about how we can do each other good
and not copy each other
because I believe that in the
end it will cost us all what we need to
survive and  these are the necessary
resources I would say
then let's have a different magazine
let's make a Lewis magazine so
let's do it ourselves for boys
there's not
yes but also for marketing they
now have everything from us in the last
Seen over the years, the marketing agencies
are of course happy that we are still
fighting each other because that’s the only way to
get discounts.
You can always accommodate them for a mark less for
your customers.
Cooperation between publishers is all the more important,
especially in the marketing area
and I think there’s spark  already a
good example of how it can also work
a few words because coppen
governance
in your role as he am the
company is now it has
others have already
done it differently so to speak we have
skipped it or talked about that
we have  then the publisher
chose other solutions, for example
Friedrich Springer with Matthias Dörfler,
are you sometimes an experiment like that,
I would have liked to have found one that
remodels it and then even increases the value
with yourself and everything, I
think you can of course  I
already have doubts about everything Springer
now and then always but
I think Springer's value is
higher today than he used to be for a
long time, it's a shame that we've
honestly often
thought about it, what would it be like if we
had Matthias Töpfner  good
question
it has a lot to do with it for us in the first place
I can only speak for us
and the way I see us as a family
we have also traveled a long way
with our management
and have also gone far
where it really is primarily
trust in the operational management is about,
I mean, our management suggested
a deal to us at the time, a prince deal
worth one
billion, there is a requirement for
that, in that case, there were three
gentlemen, but one of them has
this deal with us, so to speak  bird beaten and I
think you
really have to be able to rely on your gut feeling at that moment
and that is 100% trust
that he is suggesting the right thing to us,
interestingly enough, it is exactly the one who did
it for us and we did it, it did
n't take three minutes, he did it
presented we listened to it in the
committee said we'll do it
our mother then said but
we don't do that [ __ ] with the golden camera okay
already very smart in the front row
we then did a little bit
interestingly is exactly the and  it
was a Matthias Döpfner guy, he was
someone who was
charismatic, who
also conveyed security, who
said I'll go through it with you,
you can really
rely on it, we can do it and there is
a double bottom and  when
they fall like i catch them
right the sir is us before our
contract was even signed
before signing was
signed with another big food company
so i erased the name from my
memory ok i
really am a scorpio and never forget
and  I have learned from experience that
we cannot have Matthias Döpfner
because I am sure that,
also with regard to our
family history,
there have always been very strong
managing directors.
This is almost traumatic and
there was another one who was me
However, afterwards I
ran into Springer again, he started
when things went wrong and so
he really was the one he
just didn't pull through because he
was worried that if things went wrong he
might be held liable,
I really think that's a good thing
a bit pathetic too but I
think that as a family we are wired in such a way
that we really
want to take responsibility because any form of mistake
can happen if we are
responsible for it ourselves and that is exactly what
my siblings and now and
I do now when  that
what we are doing now goes wrong then we have to
answer to the banks I am the
face of the family I get
criticism from outside I get criticism from outside that
is exactly how we see ourselves
we could certainly
have a nice life somewhere and say
we will come like we used to  three times a year,
but we have
decided that we want to bear this
responsibility ourselves, by the way, also with regard
to our management, because
it is such a form of perhaps
unique that as a
family business we also say we stand in
front of our management and when
when it jerks and  when the wind
really
blows from the front and it has been doing that for years then
we are there and we can take it and we stand
and you learn that too in Essen you
stand there no matter what comes from the front
I also asked because  you
definitely have an ambivalent relationship with him and then you can
read about it then
you have an ambivalent relationship so on the one hand you are
also impressed by the successes
I can get a little out of it and by
the management performance but I think you were
already arguing with the associations back then
so it  it's about there is
an association where all magazine
publishers are in and there was also
Matthi long president
and then until he left Christianity again and
that was the
background that's so there
really is one I'll tell you very briefly there
are two associations  There is that for the
newspaper publishers of the BDZV and there is
that for the magazine publishers of the VDZ,
which is now called the Medienverband der Freie
Presse and in both use
both Springer and Funke and only
we two publishers were double payers and
in my company that is around
one and a half million membership fees
and  At some point the question was asked just
like Corona, so everything was a bit
more difficult, the whole advertising environment,
everything became difficult, yes, and then you
think about it. Associations are important
above all as a contribution to
the overall responsibility of our industry,
especially when you are a big player and
contributor  You are important, but it is important
that at some point, as in any large
company, you start
to question structures and, um, we
started an initiative earlier, said we
both ended up inviting the
president to visit us, and
said we would like to
think about it together  let's get
down from these huge cost structures here as double payers and both
associations were very clear and
Matthias Döpfner was there and said
absolutely right we really have to
structure Marie the VDZ now
media association of the free press was
already on the way back then and has
that has now been reformed into a federal association,
so the membership fee is also
different and at the vd at the BDZV there
was so little
need for change even then
recognizable because I believe Matthias
Döpfner is also someone who is so clear in
his visions and therefore
such an important player for  our
industry was
nonetheless there was always a
bit of the dual function of
those two hats that he wore once
as Springer CEO and once as
bdzv president and there were topics where I
also said I do
n’t think it’s right that
we as  Members of the
bdzvh were critical of him, he
went to Google Deals and
somehow it was impossible for him for a while
that publishers
could buy their copyrights
in order to get these proceeds from Google,
we never did that and it
never was  so that you
give up all your rights to some beast for it, but the point is
that we also
have to think about how to deal with these
players, Google, who can no longer be imagined without them,
and arrange ourselves in a way that is
not out of this reflex, we
close, we publishers close together
plus all the television stations
in Germany and then we are the
really big power against Google
Facebook how is that supposed to work well I
think there has to be a way of
surviving together
and there were one or two
discussions where I
really felt
like  President of this association is
not expedient and I
had the wish if you advise reform
then it will also be necessary
to talk about a different structure which and
the Media Association of the
Free Press has now done the same thing which just
no longer has a president at the front
but  possibly a board that
is also more diversely occupied so very
classic this club of
older gentlemen
also seemed to me to be too I mean I
will certainly be in 20 years so
I hope if nothing comes up
I would still be there many of the gentlemen
but probably not and me  was
a bit about the strategy for the future
and not just eating like it is nor being
eaten at
Springer also played a role
at the end
and in order to bring it to an end
it's really important that if for our
feelings  you are the president of such an
association that you can then also
really transparently discuss topics
that affect our entire industry
and in the context that you are addressing
Julian Reichelt really also
damage soiling us in
situations of justification that's the way
it is in all publishers now, you do
it that way too
and there was was
basically clearly recognizable there
is also a there is no
need to work through that together in a form
and even more so our
criticism of the association of the President that
was never personally related to Döpfner
but to the way or our suggestion
we have to stop  discuss a few things
and and we made suggestions what
we believe what can be changed together that
met with major reservations and I think we
accompanied this process for a while what
could possibly be changed
but after a while it became apparent and
there we were  as a family and very united
we will not
change the big things in this association as long as the
people involved and I also mean
the executive
committee, they will also be part of a
new board, so this
automatism for founding word and there
are everyone  in there who were there before
and they do
n't feel like making changes at all or
maybe a few new, different
heads
I think we'll have that for ourselves
or I know we've decided then
we can certainly use our energy
somewhere else more
sensibly and maybe
they need it  Association in its
restructuring now for a few more
years we’ll look at it, we reserved the
right to come back for us,
the publishers or the
newspaper shifts now measure
people who read their products or
the number of editions, um,
the largest in Germany now  second largest
what is
how is the ranking because twelve
daily newspapers
3.4 million readers in print
via all the other channels
we reach a number of 50 million so as I
said always with the unique
selling point of our
portfolio we are the only
media company magazines plus
daily newspaper and then  there is still
matzak, which I think is similar matzak
naturally has regional media, i.e.
daily newspapers,
they are now
smaller than us in terms of reach, I would say, and then
there are jumpers with pictures and the world
that are big, what else is
somehow on the radar?  who wants to be
mentioned at all who is
still somehow regularly at
the forefront
of the regional media, i.e. published in the hospital,
and television
but only with a really big player is
of course Dieter von holzbrink
Medien Holding, so Zeit
Tagesspiegel that those are yes they are
yes  really old big brands there is the
Süddeutsche
no but if you go by the number of
copies sold i don’t know the
numbers from that time but i
the time is for me as a product as a
brand right now in the digital in the
digital transformation the same price
for  Print and digital, I think that's
a real beacon, so when
we get to the point where we sell our
brand portals, the Watz Plus, for the
same money in the subscription as the
print subscription
who that's sensational if you also
know the logic in the print subscription
yes actually just the printed
paper and the pictures so pictures in the
sense of this is the photo in the e-paper we
already have moving pictures we have
something like this function on the mobile phone
if you if you press this yellow button
and each  The photo can then
move for a brief moment. That's what
we have in the e-paper. I think it's
sensational. I think that's
why it's worth it
Everything that we
also offer, for example, at sports events,
football, regional sports and things like that
via the digital subscriptions, to be
honest, and I hope that we
go exactly there with really good
content and moving images on all
possible channels, you will
also be more expensive afterwards than the old one  print subscription what
for the readers we have and who thank God we
still have an important
reliable source of information is
these famous forecasts made these
these ruler-like how things are
developing so like now for
example certain subscribers according to
death rates will disappear in the future
what  you can model everything very nicely,
so how long
do subscriptions of the current card last,
then you know exactly in three years it will be
gone look at something like that, so there
are probably models like that
you can model pretty precisely
and what's okay with the portfolio  and the
age group and the tax consultant have to
keep their eyes open for a while, of course, that works in many of
our songs, so of course we
simply have a very old readership,
and if you model that, it
will be there in ten years, that's the point
the curve doesn't go any further,
which doesn't correspond to reality either,
so we've totally
understood and thank God since 20
18 we
call it digital first, so we really called it a digital strategy including all dashboards
and technical tools that you need to
really be transparent  doing what
works because, interestingly enough,
a music review from the Hamburger
Abendblatt brings lastingly quite Konsek,
i.e. quite reliably, subscribers
digital subscribers and that has only
become obvious since we
really started to
make it transparent in the editorial departments
how is which article clicked, so
how does everyone do it
Author of every author can understand
every intern who writes what
I would have had earlier at the Süddeutsche
but the sport then I could have
shown Mr. Lorenzo I think I should have a look
here at my reports
about
the kindergarten inauguration in he
has now brought two subscribers um
and that  is an added value that is an
entrepreneurship in the editorial offices
but that is also a form of pioneering spirit
we simply have
a lot of
other very print experienced
employees in our editorial departments and who can
now technically take it with us and not
hang back and say we do it here
I had a great appointment with Gerhard
Delling, who said all this
knowledge, just what
this moving image for journalists how to do so
cutting seminars in four
weeks of training that every
editor understands it doesn’t need
the million tool from outside, but  you
can do
your own thing with a relatively large number of small effective steps make your article so much
better more interesting briefly more surprising
you want to surprise people in the future
with shorter content
moving images in sports no idea
no longer have the report on Rot-Weiss
Essen
33 minutes a lot a lot that  Goal and then
nothing happened for a long time, but then
you already have the picture in the e-paper of what
I can move and how the ball
falls into the goal and I find that alone for
what we are doing in more
transformations in freedom in
content still everything  I find it sensational that I don't
do it right and I certainly do
n't really communicate it that's why I don't look at it that much. What's the forecast with
regard to our target group? Our
aim is to deliver it to people every day in a
much better, higher-quality, more
sophisticated
way  what you
expect from us and I think we've been
in the last few years, especially at Funke, we
didn't care enough, we optimized what was
somehow economically squeezed out,
dismissed people who we now
urgently need, especially in the
editorial offices, far too much in the  with these
own issues, which unfortunately
were also the way they are in our family,
millions of hundreds of millions
unfortunately left the company and didn't
go into the company, but that's
part of our history and
I think what I
want to say is very important because I  experienced all this together
with my family because I
experienced all this together with my siblings
and also know, by the way, we are
the three owners now, so our mother
also has one percent
and of course we are aware that we should
never argue with each other now, so we
we really can't afford it anymore
in the truest sense of the word it's
a burden on the one hand
because you think you have to sometimes,
we're a family too and
you have completely different issues
and
I got through it anyway  this time also now when it comes to
taking over our last
shares, we really
all three sat down again with intensive
coaching and said
we really want to bear this responsibility together for our life as a threesome
because I also do that a bit
that the family disputes are that
one that is the economic pressure is
the other but the main thing is
that you as the owner always have to
have an exit I think that is very
important because that was there for us children
there was never anyone asked
maybe they wanted to do something else
or  Do you
maybe want to sell your shares but it was
always about
making life easier don't you think
mine I was missing something crazy
and I can only speak for myself
I know that for my
life it's somewhere I'm a bit also
in terms of personality development  because
now at 50 a bit further
than at 30 but I think it
all makes sense why you are there
and why I am a woman
who maybe opens other doors but
also causes more discussions
Discussions are good and I want to make
my contribution  I can do this by saying that
as the owner I can
also address things publicly with the
claim of let's
discuss it because a boss can't fire me tomorrow
or I somehow
have an appointment then you feel the
need
to make a few points with him then you call
him or he calls you and says hey, they still
give me this reach, they'll come
by again or how's it going, so of course we have
that was also the case with Ms. Merkel,
so of course we have topics for our
industry, which I always do  for our
entire industry Lectures you
said correctly earlier now we are no longer
in the association but of course I am sitting with
Mr Scholz with the claim that we
need support at a political
level on issues that I have been talking
to Mrs Merkel about for five years
sat and said that,
then
nothing ever happened in all these coalition rounds
to say very clearly, so if the
minimum is now raised even further, then
you can no longer deliver a magazine in a certain
region economically,
that means the newspaper is
not dying out now because the  People
no longer want to read it per se, but
simply because delivery is no longer
economically feasible and
the region is then more or less newspaper-free without
that being the case, and
that happens above all in the
regions where we also these people we
urgently  don't even need to
get a job as a deliverer because it
just pays better at Amazon or in other industries under different
working conditions
you know driving off at night and three you used to know in Essen I
don't know if that had to be the case but
newspapers were also delivered at night
or  in the afternoon, well, that
's just a job for
me, I wrote and there it is, and
then of course I'll try
to place our needs on all the channels available to me,
and I might have the
advantage that we as a company
might also be a bit involved  our
family history can
at least be seen and heard, which
incidentally I particularly like because the
topic of appreciation was mentioned earlier,
when my siblings and I took over the
minority shares, i.e. the shares of the
minority shareholders,
Mr. Steinmeier, our
Federal President, invited me to tea
and I sat at
Belvedere Palace and  He said I would like to
thank you for being brave
and for doing this and for
making your contribution to media diversity, so we can't sell anything right now,
but I found it incredibly
important because you need a little feeling from time to time
So politics is we see ourselves as the fourth
pillar of democracy and yet it's
not against each other and this kind of
campaign journalism that is very partly typical of tabloid media
and you have to finish everyone off
and take pictures of Mrs. Merkel when she's
sitting in the car in the morning in such a way that  that
you just come across as [ __ ],
I don't know if that's ultimately useful for all of us,
let's leave
one thing at the very end, at
least nothing more
to address in any way, because it's also in
Essen and there
was Karstadt, yes, and there was
also a woman who took over that, so to speak,
and also a
media manager who actually
took over, namely Thomas Will Lauf who is
then somehow taken over, I think it was
my conviction, so in the end it wasn’t his
fault, but of course he was
also part of the process and
is no longer there today  forever in
shape so it's a completely different one
you have if you follow something like that yes even
if you want to yes also grew up there there are
parallels if ok uhm
sometimes you just get a
little queasy when you look at it
you mean  what is it exactly up to
people and
can I can I
really and amusingly I actually thought about it last night and amusingly but I
thought a little bit that you I
don't know why but that you might ask me
in that direction afterwards
mittelhoff whom I personally  never
knew so it was really like that
from Günter Grotkamp I think what
a phenomenon is maybe especially in
our industry is
that from a certain
salary range it
can happen very quickly that someone could become
a manager there I would also
women  not at all to rule out
that at some point they will fall into a kind of
big goods, so somehow with
millions of salaries
that they pull out of the optimization of a
company so yes for yes there
that they then at some point mentally take the
wrong turn and forget
what their actual task is, namely
responsible for the company
and I can only say one thing for myself
today that it is the task
of us publishers, so now
transferred to our industry,
we are responsible for putting our
company in responsible
hands and I have conducted a lot of
personal interviews
so it was  If you are
looking for a management job, you go to
a personnel consultancy and then
the candidates are introduced and then I
always get a long list of things that
they have all already done, which is also
important: experience, but I
also find social skills and
ultimately security  and
you can only decide based on gut feeling
to put your company in the right hands you can
certainly only look in front of people and
we have found that
one or the other in a completely different,
smaller dimension then, however, as
Media manager and that's where our industry is
perhaps predestined because we
just write about the stories
that life writes that's a very
vain industry and that might lead
to you suddenly throwing your tie in
the corner and now like
me saying media manager and
whatnot  costs the world and then
you somehow forget that the most important thing
is that the company is
doing well and not the manager and that's
why I would strongly advocate
moving away from the bonuses and in
centivations that the management
deserves the most important ones, even in these times
We actually pay people in our age
the worst, and they are the ones
who stand in the demo with the camera,
who go to the Ukraine to
report on the spot, and
I'm ashamed of our entire industry that
we still don't understand enough there
that what these people
show in terms of courage, the crisis reporters
are one thing, but it starts with every
afd demo, every journalist and especially
the photojournalists and those who
are there with the camera, who
are therefore visible to the lying press
screaming and
preventing it  want the
journalists to do their job, they
really get punched in the face
and
we don't give these people enough and there are too many
board members on floors that haven't
really experienced a single demo up close, let alone
in an
editorial office  picked up a pen
okay Julia so I find it incredibly
honest really really interesting as you can
see it wasn't clear to me that
this superstructure behind the
decision
that's really not just
economically driven in your form
so yes  I would now, even if
that is perhaps a bit presumptuous,
first of all
say thank you to Mr Stollmeier for the commitment
to the work and in the end of course
for food instead of in the slopes
and I'll keep my fingers crossed for you that
it works that you there  It's
also finding its way into the digital world and
yes, with the journalistic model that allows
me to move forward, thank you, thank
you, and maybe finally from
me, yes, that was very honest, but I
hope that this gives
some people the feeling that it's
worth it  to really talk about
what your own story is, so
especially in our industry I believe
very much in talking to each other
and not about each other, which I
certainly do when I publicly
criticize a corporation for the way
they treat our most valuable
asset  But I also see that
as my
task and somehow
from my heart I don't want to, how do you call
it a murder group, make
everything clear, thank you very much